j'ai présenté la mission n°1 de Planet :
lancer une flotte de satellites
photographiant la Terre entière, tous les jours,
et en démocratiser l'accès.
Notre problème était simple.
Les images satellites en ligne datent d'il y a plusieurs années,
or, l'activité humaine évolue chaque jour, chaque semaine et chaque mois,
et on ne peut pas réparer ce qu'on ne voit pas.
Nous avons voulu permettre aux gens d'être témoins du changement et d'agir.
La magnifique photo « La Bille bleue », prise par l'équipe d'Apollo 17, en 1972,
nous a aidés à prendre conscience de la fragilité de notre planète.
On a cherché à renforcer cette expérience
afin de donner aux gens les outils pour agir et préserver la planète.
Après nos nombreux projets Apollo,
qui ont lancé la plus grande flotte de satellites de l'histoire humaine,
nous avons atteint notre but.
Aujourd'hui, Planet photographie la Terre entière, chaque jour.
Mission accomplie.
(Applaudissements)
Merci.
Il a fallu 21 lancements de fusées –
cette animation donne l'impression que c'est simple – ça ne l'est pas.
Et nous avons maintenant plus de 200 satellites en orbite,
envoyant des données à 31 stations, réparties sur notre planète.
Au total, nous recevons 1,5 million d'images en 29 mégapixel par jour.
Et pour n'importe quel endroit sur Terre,
nous avons en moyenne plus de 500 images.
C'est une énorme base de données, informant sur des changements immenses.
Beaucoup de gens utilisent ces images.
Le secteur agricole y a recours pour améliorer les récoltes des agriculteurs.
Les entreprises de cartographie, pour enrichir leurs cartes en ligne.
Les États, pour sécuriser leurs frontières
ou réagir aux inondations, aux incendies et aux séismes.
De nombreuses ONG s'en servent
pour suivre la déforestation et l'arrêter,
aider à localiser les réfugiés fuyant la Birmanie,
ou repérer toutes les actions de la crise actuelle en Syrie,
en surveillant la responsabilité de chaque partie.
Aujourd'hui, je suis ravi de vous présenter Planet stories.
Tout le monde peut se connecter sur planet.com,
créer un compte et accéder à notre photothèque en ligne.
C'est comme Google Earth, sauf que les images sont actualisées
et qu'on peut retracer leur évolution dans le temps.
On peut comparer deux dates
et observer les changements spectaculaires qui se produisent.
Ou aussi regarder un accéléré des 500 images disponibles
et voir ce qui a beaucoup changé avec le temps.
On peut aussi le partager sur les réseaux sociaux.
C'est plutôt cool.
(Applaudissements)
Merci.
Cet outil était initialement destiné aux journalistes
en quête d'informations objectives sur l'actualité mondiale.
Depuis, on l'a ouvert à tous,
pour un usage à but non-lucratif ou personnel.
On espère qu'il permettra aux gens de localiser et voir les évolutions du monde
pour passer à l'action.
L'humanité bénéficie actuellement de cette base de données sur notre planète,
évoluant au fil du temps.
En quoi consiste la prochaine Mission 2 ?
Pour résumer, c'est l'espace couplé avec l'IA.
Nous utilisons l'intelligence artificielle
pour détecter des objets dans l'ensemble des images satellitaires.
Les mêmes outils d'IA permettant de repérer les chats dans les vidéos en ligne
peuvent être utilisés pour trouver des informations sur nos images.
Imaginez qu'on puisse dire : voici un bateau, ici un arbre,
une voiture, une route, un bâtiment et un camion.
Si on pouvait les repérer dans les millions d'images
prises chaque jour,
alors on créerait une base de données
de tous les grands objets sur Terre, chaque jour.
Cette base de données est exploitable.
C'est précisément ce que nous faisons.
Voici un prototype, basé sur notre interface.
Voici Pékin.
Imaginons que l'on veuille compter les avions de l'aéroport.
On sélectionne l'aéroport
et ça trouve les avions sur l'image d'aujourd'hui.
Il va rechercher les avions dans la masse d'images précédentes,
puis il nous montre tous les avions à l'aéroport de Pékin au fil du temps.
Bien sûr, on pourrait en faire de même pour tous les aéroports du monde.
Regardons maintenant le port de Vancouver.
On va faire pareil, mais avec des bateaux cette fois.
On zoome sur Vancouver, on sélectionne la zone,
on cherche les bateaux,
et il trouve tous les bateaux.
Imaginez l'utilité de ce programme pour les garde-côtes
qui cherchent à détecter et arrêter la pêche illégale.
En effet, les bateaux de pêche autorisés
transmettent leurs géolocalisations via des balises SIA.
Mais on trouve souvent des bateaux qui ne le font pas.
Les images ne mentent pas.
Les garde-côtes peuvent les utiliser
pour repérer ces bateaux de pêche illégaux.
Bientôt, après les bateaux et les avions, ce sera
tous les autres objets.
On pourra émettre des flux de données,
sur ces lieux et ces objets, à travers le temps,
qui s'intégreront automatiquement aux flux de travail des gens.
A terme, nous aurons des navigateurs plus sophistiqués
où les gens pourront obtenir différentes sources.
Et, en fin de compte, je nous imagine extraire toutes ces images
pour faire de la Terre une interface interactive.
Imaginez qu'on puisse dire :
« Au fait, combien de maisons y a-t-il au Pakistan ?
Montre-moi leur évolution dans le temps. »
« Combien y a-t-il d'arbres en Amazonie
et où se trouvaient ceux abattus
depuis la dernière semaine ? »
Ce serait génial, non ?
Eh bien, c'est ce vers où nous allons.
Ce projet s'appelle « Queryable Earth ».
Notre première mission était donc de photographier chaque jour la Terre entière
et de rendre ces images accessibles.
Notre deuxième mission est d'indexer tous les objets terrestres dans le temps
pour les rendre « trouvables ».
Je vous laisserai sur cette analogie.
Google indexe tout ce qui est sur Internet pour le rendre trouvable.
Nous indexons tout ce qui est sur Terre pour le rendre trouvable.
Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)